[Music]
all right let's talk android 13. hey
what's up i'm kbhd here so i just did my
ios 16 hands-on a couple weeks ago did
my walkthrough and demo and everything
so as i was digging through android 13
for a sort of similar demo
two things struck me one
the ios videos always get just
absolutely nuts views literally every
single time and it's not just because
the iphone is already popular but ios
updates just get saturation
so quickly there's a couple sources
estimating ios 15 was running on 90 of
compatible iphones well within a year of
it going out so across the board most
people who had bought an iphone in the
last four years knew that they're gonna
get this software now in android land on
the other hand as of a week ago the
distribution chart looks a little
something like this which shows that
about 13 and a half percent are on the
latest version android 12. a much larger
27
are on a two-channeled version android
11 and then another 22 are on android 10
and then the fragmentation just
continues back from there so this
android 13 stuff i'm about to go over
a few people like pixel owners in the
beginning will be the ones to get this
but then it'll it'll much more slowly
trickle out to other phones as they get
updated month by month and that's sort
of a general theme here but then number
two in both camps these updates are more
minor than ever obviously they're both
very mature in ios you could consider
the new lock screen overhaul pretty
major but other than that a bunch of
smaller stuff and then with android we
just had the big material you overhaul
with android 12. so with 13 they didn't
really have to overhaul things again
it's a lot of smaller tweaks and so
that's what we're seeing but i still do
think a lot of the small stuff adds up
to quality of life improvements the best
analogy if you look at the easter eggs
this is the android 12 easter egg from
last year and this is the android 13
easter egg it's almost the same thing
but you can tell it's a little different
but hey here we are with the very latest
and greatest from google i have it on my
pixel 6 pro and so i've gone through all
of the many many updates and gone
through the liberty of picking my top
five best android 13 features so i'm
gonna start at number five which is the
clipboard there are a bunch of really
solid improvements to the clipboard for
copying and pasting within android so
first thing you're gonna notice when you
go to copy something the new box pops up
in the lower left corner whether it's
text or an address or url or whatever
you copy when you copy text the phone
will now give you a preview with the
option to tap on that box and then edit
the text in the clipboard so whatever
you modify in here will be saved in your
clipboard so that you can paste it later
and then if you copy an image it'll
automatically take you straight into
markup so you can write on it or crop it
or save it whatever you want to do and
then your phone will recognize sensitive
information if it's stored in your
clipboard and automatically clear it
after some time i believe it's one hour
so for example my package tracking app
every time i open it right away it just
looks it sees what's in my clipboard in
case i just copied a tracking number
from another app and it asks me if i
want to paste it but if i just copied
like a social security number or a
password or something else random like
that i don't want that in there so
anytime any app might look into your
clipboard it'll be empty because of this
new android little clipboard update and
google is also now working on an
official built into android universal
copy and paste between phones and
tablets so it'll just work across we
already know a pixel tablet is coming
it's still a few months away i guess
it's sometime next year but looking
forward to that they've done a bunch of
stuff in the tablet world in this
android 13 update but that's one of them
the clipboard will now work across both
so that number four is security in
general lots of nice security and
privacy improvements i think my favorite
is that when you give photo access to
apps now you can just choose a few
photos to give it access to instead of
your entire library so that catches up
to what ios has been doing for a little
bit and also now notifications are all
opt-in so apps have to ask you for
permission to send notifications instead
of any being allowed by default there's
also now an active app indicator at the
bottom of the notification slider maybe
that's a less security and just more of
being able to see what's running and
closing out anything that you might not
realize is killing your battery but yeah
it's also just convenient so the number
three is some nice audio enhancement
stuff so android 13 will now natively
support spatial audio and bluetooth le
for higher quality low energy and lower
latency audio all good stuff side note i
am testing the pixel buds pro right now
as of today when i'm using them they do
not support spatial audio but there also
is a blog post that says that they're
going to be adding it later this year so
maybe a firmware update will eventually
give me that but so far they are pretty
impressive stay tuned for that review
because that's coming up soon but then
number two this is a really interesting
one apparently was one of the most
requested features in android for the
last little bit and now they're adding
it which is app specific language
support so if you're bilingual you speak
more than one language but maybe you
only use that second language in a
certain app maybe you have a family
group chat and whatsapp or you have a
very specific use case where you just
use one app in a different language
now android will natively support that
exact switch without you having to work
around it so you go to settings
system
languages and input and then app
languages app developers will have to
opt in to do this so not every app shows
up here right off the bat but i believe
this should be a pretty quick like check
box that they flip and then they'll be
supported in multiple languages the
whole system ui changes to be the new
language just for that one app that's
sweet i'm not even someone who will
actually use that feature but i can
understand how that'd be very useful so
that's pretty cool so then last but not
least number one is aesthetics so
material u was the big overhaul for
android 12. that was the big visual
change that they'd made so now they're
down to tweaking a lot of the things
that they'd you know initially changed
for android 12 and i think a lot of
these changes are good so in the
customization section the theme picker
for your wallpapers is much more precise
there's 16 different multi-color options
and
16 different single color options now
instead of the four of each we had
before and there's a lot more
granularity between them then there's
the media player this one's nice the
notification is bigger and it changes
color based on the media that you're
listening to so if it's music or a
podcast it's got the album art going and
then it also has a squiggly line when
there's actually something playing i'm
not gonna say what that looks like but
yeah if you tap the playback location
there's a bigger volume slider and you
can quickly switch to or add more
sources like headphones or speakers or
your car or whatever but that new media
player is sweet and then there's even
just some tiny tiny visual stuff like
there's a slightly new lock screen clock
there's a slightly new unlocking
animation if you'll notice that
the shortcut to get to settings has
moved from the middle to the bottom of
quick settings to be much more reachable
actually like it here and the gesture
bar at the bottom is now slightly larger
and thicker see told you it was minor
there's a lot of little stuff but again
it adds up to quality of life
improvements there's also a ton of bug
fixes and performance improvements and
android runtime improvements hopefully
things are generally less buggy and more
smooth
there's a whole page of just dozens and
dozens of bug fixes that they've added
i'll link it below if you want to read
through those but ideally i mean so far
should be running better on phones like
the pixel 6 than android 12 was i do
also want to mention though i think
there's one thing that got worse i think
they low-key made some of the haptic
patterns
worse i hope they think a little bit
about those but generally that's pretty
much it that's android 13 for you let me
know if you're uh hoping to get that
update on whatever phone you're using
and let me know what your favorite
feature is in the comment section below
either way
that's a minute thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]